ladies and gentlemen welcome inside the
new studio I know it looks very much the
same but it is very much different and I
know it will probably sound a little
different for a couple of days dealing
with an echo you don't need to email me
about the echo we're dealing with it's
still treating the room uh please bear
with me as we work through some
technical elements here and I know it
looks like I have a wire coming out of
my right arm and I do it's been
implanted to connect directly to the
studio no I'm kidding uh let's get right
into it because there is so much to talk
about it is not yet over in Arizona in a
number of different ways and of course
it is completely over in Arizona in
terms of Cary lake is not going to be
the next Governor from Arizona so let's
take it step by step in Maricopa County
they they held and by they I mean the
county authorities and people who
believe Carey Lake actually won they
held a hearing and the hearing was so
insane and so depraved and so outrageous
that within just moments it went bad I
want to look at a couple of these
moments with you again as a reminder
that these people will go for years you
know how sometimes you look at a little
puppy dog or a toddler and they seem to
have endless energy and you say well
I've already thrown the ball a hundred
times I've already picked up the spoon
500 times and it's still interesting and
you still want to do it again and the
answer is they will go for years they
are still not over the results of the
2020 election and now they are getting
going with 2022 here is a woman who says
she is there somehow related to wanting
a new election and also her children
were once taken away from her which is
certainly odd take a listen to this
I'm questioning why is nobody talking
about us over the media
I am nobody like I'm just like mother
trying to save my family because my kids
were taken from me when they were little
because I fought for them medical
freedom because so it sounds like the
children were taken away for for reasons
of neglect and this is the person who
knows we should have a new election I I
don't go there okay but I want to tell
you this guys
like a joke but please Arizona I love
Arizona I love all of you I love you
Stephen I voted for you okay this is not
about hate uh Love and Hate You Know
What Love Is to say no to wrongdoing you
know and and please try to understand
those people how upset they are yeah
yeah everybody's very upset because
they're candidate lost and yet they want
a new election because of that if we won
it was fair if we lost it was rigged
here's another woman who believes there
were hundreds of thousands of people in
Arizona who could not vote there's a
statistician on
online guys it's a statistician who's
done statistics what else do you need
disenfranchisement based on Richard's
numbers and how he calculated people
waiting in line it's up for hundreds of
thousands of people that we're not able
to vote right that they disenfranchised
the second thing is everybody that's
been paying attention for way years
before 2020 and then when 2020 came
along and they've been paying attention
since then do not trust these machines
there have been investigations going
Mike pillow's one of those guys going on
for two years the evidence is in they've
got it all they're gonna it's gonna
bubble up to the Top If We Had
journalists that were doing their job
and asking questions people would know
this by now but they don't so here's my
next point it's gonna Bubble Up This is
a fork in the road right now today now
by Bubble Up it sort of sounds like
she's increasingly saying that this
might lead to violence and again think
of it 2.4 million people voted in
Arizona a few weeks ago she says
hundreds of thousands were
disenfranchised that sort of means like
a third of the electorate or at least 10
15 20 it's Bonkers now then came another
woman who was even more dire and
apocalyptic in her concerns she says if
this election gets certified it's going
to get very bad very quickly Justice you
high and mighty politicians don't even
know the meaning of the word fairness
which of you has any left not one all
your dealings are crooked you give
Justice in exchange for bribes these men
are born Sinners lying from their
earliest Words Their poisonous deadly
snakes cobras that close their ears to
the most expert of Charmers so this is
this is like biblical stuff right oh God
break off their fangs tear out the teeth
of these young lions Lord let them
disappear like water into thirsty ground
make their weapons useless in their
hands let them be as snails that
dissolve into slime okay I think you
basically get it just crazy apocalyptic
stuff here is another woman who came
forward and said that the board of
electors in Maricopa County are Traders
Tony
yeah I came here today to get an up
close and personal look at the seven
traitors to the United States
Constitution okay again please
you were set to receive a subpoena this
morning at 9 30.
what did you do you called your meeting
for 8 A.M
what are you hiding right we all know
nothing good happens at eight in the
morning if you hold an 8 A.M meeting it
must be for some kind of subterfusion
then lastly here's a guy again with just
more like apocalyptic Bible type stuff
and then he throws in some Klaus shop
World economic Forum conspiracy theories
imagine getting out of bed for this some
people traveled from other states which
by the way what stake do they have in
Arizona that's a whole other question
the wicked flee when no one is chasing
them but The Godly are bold and lion
see any bold people who are lions here I
see bald people
they're committed to this thing so am I
when there is moral rot within a nation
it's government topples easily but with
honest and sensible leaders there is
stability I want you to feel [ __ ] so
there is this guy and they are going to
achieve nothing they continue to be
convinced that they are right that they
actually won despite there being no
evidence whatsoever
Kerry lake is playing along with these
people Carrie Lake continues to say oh
it's not over it's this that the other
thing it is over and there is one
Arizona county who refuses to accept it
let's talk about that next the science
tells us that one of the best ways to
get consistent deep sleep is lowering
your core body temperature when your
body stays cooler at night you're more
comfortable and your sleep is better our
sponsor sleep me is the home of chili
sleep the customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions that can
improve your sleep by keeping you cooler
at night there are three different chili
sleep systems there's the uler the cube
and the new Doc Pro with double the
cooling power all three systems are
water-based temperature controlled
mattress toppers that fit over your
existing mattress to provide you with
your ideal sleep temperature you can go
as cool as 55 degrees you can go really
hot if you want I keep mine at 60
beautiful temperature for me
don't wake up hot and sweaty chilly
sleep keeps me asleep all night it feels
great I didn't know it was possible to
love sleeping even more than I already
did go to sleep.me slash Pacman to learn
more and get 25 off your new chili Sleep
System click the link below to start
staying cool at night